invité à présent du 7 8 Charles Huet
bonsoir vous êtes l'auteur de ce guide
Médine emploi votre constat le made in
France tout le monde en parle pas
forcément beaucoup de monde s'y retrouve
finalement ce qui compte pour vous c'est
l'impact de nos achats sur l'emploi en
France et regarde les chiffres du
chômage annoncé aujourd'hui je rappelle
3,2 millions de demandeurs d'emploi en
mars c'est effectivement important un
exemple on va commencer directement avec
un exemple la viande sous vide si tu as
un groupe Bigard Charal 1015000 emplois
en France même en tête de sa catégorie
selon votre livre
Ubisoft pour les jeux vidéo 1500 points
en France c'est aussi votre classement
nous viennent ces différents chiffres
écoutez c'est la synthèse et le
recoupement de divers sources d'abord la
communication institutionnelle des
entreprises le rapport annuel et puis la
presse économique
régionale la presse économique mensuelle
quotidienne hebdomadaire la presse
locale qui fait beaucoup de reportages
sur sur les entreprises de la région et
puis et puis à son de blogs qui font de
la veille sur le sujet et des bases de
données des données professionnelles sur
la géographie des usines en France et
sur la santé financière il y a
énormément de chiffres pour les amateurs
de chiffres c'est un régal forcément
puisque vous classez tout ça par nombre
d'emplois l'impact sur l'emploi en
France quel que soit la société qu'elle
soit française ou non et on en vient à
cette question du made in France on va
l'aborder mais juste sur la méthodologie
sur le travail vous avez travaillé seul
vous avez été aidé combien de temps ça
vous a pris parce que ça semble assez
titanesque imposant comme travail c'est
ça c'était mes travaux d'Hercule quand
même je l'ai fait tout seul j'ai pas été
aidé j'ai mis un an à trouver un éditeur
et j'ai bossé en chambre
devant mon ordinateur et en bibliothèque
pendant un an et demi est-ce qu'il y a
des entreprises qui vous ont contacté
depuis la publication pour vous dire ces
chiffres là là vous vous trompez ça
correspond pas du tout pas encore mais
la plupart des entreprises sont mises en
avant je cite surtout les vertueuses
parce que le point n'est pas de les les
mettre l'index le point c'est de les
encourager c'est d'informer les
consommateurs qu'ils existent qu'ils
sont accessibles à nos caddie et qu'on
peut faire le choix de l'emploi avec
notre carte bleue
donc dans les sièges très récemment
smugler c'est le costume made in France
et son patron m'ont encouragé et costume
c'est ça non je l'ai acheté comme comme
tout le monde mais je crois qu'il y a de
plus en plus d'entreprises françaises
qui comme ça s'entraident et se mettent
en avant mutuellement pour pas parce que
pour s'en sortir on est dans le même
bateau quoi mais vous voulez démontrer
quoi que le made in France justement ça
ne veut rien dire non je veux c'était
pas une démonstration ce livre c'est un
guide pratique c'est un guide pratique à
destination des consommateurs des
ménagères en particulier donc le point
c'était d'offrir d'abord une synthèse
complète et exhaustive des produits made
in France de recenser ces marques sur
une cinquantaine de nos produits de
courant donc sur le panier de la
ménagère
de voilà nos vêtements à notre voiture à
notre nourriture notre équipement de la
maison notre high-tech notre hygiène
beauté
donc le but c'était surtout de fournir
une information accessible
compréhensible aux ménagères pour leur
expliquer que en sur tous leurs produits
il existe une option made in France et
puis pour leur expliquer la vie de ces
entreprises combien précisément de
salariés les emplois ou et pourquoi il
réussissent à pourquoi il réussissent à
continuer de d'employant en France sur
des produits magnifiques mais le produit
français ça signifie quelque chose bien
sûr que ça signifie quelque chose après
dans made in France
surtout quand il a été repris par les
politiques il y a une logique
protectionniste il y a une logique de
rejet de l'étranger qui n'est pas du
tout ma logique moi ce qui m'importe
c'est pas que ce soit rien n'est aucun
produit manufacturé n'est 100% made in
France tous les produits qui nous
entourent sont le fruit de la
coopération spontanée d'entrepreneurs du
monde entier et ça nous enrichisse tous
le point c'était moi ce qui m'importe en
tant que consommateur c'est de savoir
combien de salariés précisément
dépendent de mon achat voilà donc c'est
ça moi ce qui m'a apporté c'est savoir
ce produit il est pas made in France ou
même pas midi France la question c'est
il est made in combien d'emplois voilà
et il est classé ensuite chaque
entreprise est classée les plus
vertueuse vous l'avez dit c'est pas
l'ensemble des entreprises mais celles
qui s'illustre le plus sur l'impact sur
l'emploi dans leur activité qui sont
mentionnées dans ce dans ce guide le
produit en français justement va juste
faire une petite pause nous sommes allés
à la rencontre du public yvelinois 5
continents pour leur demander si ça
signifie quelque chose pour eux au
moment de l'achat le produit en français
la question c'est ce qu'on a vraiment
les moyens quoi mais c'est sûr que ça
permet de maintenir l'emploi etc enfin
on voit qu'on a on a perdu tout un pan
de notre industrie que
aujourd'hui on est bien embêté parce que
on est plus compétitif bien sûr c'est
important de produire en France bah pour
l'économie pour le travail ah oui
français parce que je suis sûr que
c'était bon qualité
nationalités sont pas forcément liées
c'est très important de produire en
France pour l'économie française et pour
les bons produits français je pense que
c'est important de produire en France
pourquoi pour faire marcher l'économie
tout simplement
maintenant il faut que les Français
soient prêts à payer un petit peu plus
cher le problème est là il faut toujours
envisager il est toujours entreprendre
en France parce qu'il y a beaucoup de
talents donc j'encourage tout le monde
de continuer à produire en France
il faut produire en France vous entendez
dire c'est bien c'est de mon témoignage
c'était témoignage là je suis ravi parce
que surtout surtout le dernier et puis
tous on voit qu'il y a une vraie prise
de conscience du made in France depuis
que verrou a posé dessus sur la table à
la gendarme médiatique en novembre 2011
on entend pas mal parler de la question
du prix
la réalité c'est que
est un frein à l'achat made in France au
moins autant manque d'information que la
question du prix et moi le prix de mon
costume de ma 208 je peux pas jouer
dessus par contre je pouvais jouer à
titre individuel sur l'information de ma
mère de votre mère de vous de votre
femme de mes déménager ce qui ce qui est
un frein aussi important au made in
France c'est que c'est qu'on ne sait pas
ce qui est made in France c'est que la
nationalité apparente des entreprises et
bien souvent trompeuse on l'a vu avec la
Toyota Yaris la Smart
inversement avec des petites citadines
de marque française fabriquées à
l'étranger donc il y a une question de
prix certes après ça dépend faut
toujours comparer à quelque chose de
comparable moi ce costume il est smugler
made in Limoges il est moins cher que
bien des marques haut de gamme made in
Roumanie ou Asie du Sud-Est donc donc
c'est pas toujours plus cher c'est pas
vrai c'est vrai aussi que la nationalité
et pas forcément corrélé à la qualité il
faut que les entreprises françaises
prouvent chaque jour leurs qualités et
elles y travaillent mais pour ça il faut
les soutenir un peu et pour les soutenir
il faut savoir c'est l'information qui
dit ce guide des visions du Puy fleuri
le guide des produits made in emploi ça
veut dire que vous imaginez les
ménagères qui les fameuses ménagères que
vous mentionnez faire leur course avec
le livre en tout cas la voir à la maison
et le consulter à l'occasion
se les faire offrir à l'occasion de la
fête des mères qui arrive par leurs
enfants l'occasion de la fête des pères
aussi parce que je me fais gronder très
fortement dans l'oreillette parce qu'il
n'y a pas que déménagères qui font les
courses ça c'est vrai c'est vrai moi je
vous expliquerai avec notre assistante
tout à l'heure tout à fait mais c'est la
preuve moi je c'est la preuve de du rôle
crucial qu'on les femmes les citoyennes
les travailleuses et les consommatrices
françaises pour les mettre en avant vous
êtes aussi sévère avec le travail des
élus des ministres parce que vous lui
mentionnez vous mentionnez le travail
qui a été fait est-ce que c'est un
engagement politique aussi ce livre moi
j'ai des convictions affichées en
conclusion du livre je suis
fondamentalement libéral je pense que
dans le made in France il y a cette idée
que le pouvoir et l'efficacité et
l'action légitime elle est dans la
société civile elle est dans la société
civile des consommateurs des
entrepreneurs des associations des
individus c'est nous qui faisons la
France et effectivement je pense que
l'interventionnisme d'État est plus un
frein et un problème pour nos
entreprises made in France que que qu'un
atout le médicament ça a pas besoin de
ministère il a besoin de marcher libre
et il a besoin de compétitivité et pour
ça il faut baisser les dépenses
publiques baisser les taxes réduire le
nombre de réglementations et arrêter de
s'agiter au bénéfices de sa seule
carrière politique et puis après pour
vous c'est quoi c'est de vous engager en
politique justement
pourquoi pourquoi pas pourquoi pas parce
que à un moment donné
c'est la le sens de ma démarche
on peut pas on peut pas se contenter des
discours et des Yaka faucon et
il faut un moment donné mettre les mains
dans le cambouis et s'engager à titre
individuel donc peut-être c'est pas
l'objectif l'objectif aujourd'hui c'est
de c'est de développer de le faire
vendre c'est de le faire lire c'est de
le développer sur d'autres supports
application iPhone web la labilisation
enfin vraiment c'est de travailler un
écosystème marchand et rentable privé
parce que je pense que le marché
c'est vous êtes une entreprise privée à
téléfils 78 c'est pas complètement et
non ça fonctionne aussi sur des
subventions publiques c'est un peu
problématique du coup quand on est censé
contrôler nos dirigeants mais en tout
cas l'information est un produit
d'entrepreneurs privés à mon avis en
tout cas si vous vous engagez en
politique ce sera pas aux côtés d'Arnaud
Montebourg ministre du redressement
productif puisque je vais vous citer au
lieu de promettre mesures
protectionniste nationalisation et être
violation du droit de la propriété la
Chenou et laisse leur chance aux
Français c'est ça mais c'est mon message
c'est clair je pense que je pense que le
made in France a pas besoin de ministère
il a besoin d'entrepreneurs
bénéficiant d'un environnement fiscal et
réglementaire le plus léger possible
qui ne soit pas insulté à chaque acte de
gestion et qui soit plutôt qui soit
plutôt qui soit plutôt félicité pour la
richesse et les emplois qui créent dans
ce pays parce que c'est eux qui créent
qui créent l'emploi armement de Bourg ne
fait que dépenser de l'argent chaque
semaine les artisans les entrepreneurs
français font plus pour l'emploi que
Arnaud Montebourg dans toute sa carrière
voilà ce que je pense et ça vaut pour
mon bourre qui est actuellement au
pouvoir comme pour tous ses copains de
tout bord je pense que
56% de dépenses publiques dans ce pays
c'est ce qui fait que nos entreprises
sont pas compétitives à l'export et
c'est qui ce qui fait que nos produits
made in France sont chers donc il y a un
vrai engagement politique derrière aussi
ce livre citoyen mais aussi forcément
politique on peut pas s'empêcher de ce
qui est intéressant avec ce livre
au-delà d'être pratique je pense que
c'est un bon précis d'économie distiller
au supermarché à offrir aussi à son
cousin son petit frère à son fils qui
serait en terminale ES pour lui
expliquer la microéconomie et l'économie
concrète réelle et on découvre que on
découvre la réalité de l'économie donc
quand on a l'information on peut je
pouvais pas la garder pour moi
effectivement
certains lycéens peut-être que dans leur
copie d'économie ils vont citer votre
livre jean-luette Le guide des produits
made in emploie il y aura juste pour te
conclure des mises à jour c'est un guide
c'est une première édition l'idée c'est
d'en faire le guide Michelin du
supermarché donc oui chaque année chaque
année une fin d'en faire une réédition
annuelle et puis d'autres supports une
application étant est en cours merci à
vous et c'est aux éditions Dupuis
fleurie merci